what's up guys first off I apologize for
the crappy quality and I apologize for
the way I look I've literally stayed up
all night so I can capture these
nominations as they are announced I am a
tired man I'm I'm weary i I need some
sleep
see last year when they announced that
Extremely Loud and Incredibly Close was
nominated for Best Picture there's no
way I could have captured a more genuine
reaction than my initial shock at
hearing that and a lot of people really
liked that video and I was surprised
because I just I don't know I was just
surprised I've gotten a lot of tweets
and messages from people asking me to do
another video like hey Chris are you
gonna do another video I want to know
you're gonna do it you're gonna do one
again do a live reaction Chris Ruger oh
like it's a couple my predictions and
hopes I'm hoping that Jennifer Lawrence
gets nominated for Best Actress for
silver linings playbook I'm thinking
that Jessica Chastain will get nominated
for zero dark thirty
it'd be nice to see Robert DeNiro for
Best Supporting Actor for silver linings
Bradley Cooper for best actor Leonardo
DiCaprio for Best Supporting Actor I've
given up hope that the Academy will
nominate Christopher Nolan for director
ever I don't think that'll happen at
Dark Knight II didn't get nominated for
it so I probably won't get nominated for
Dark Knight Rises either I'm thinking
Spielberg could probably get a
nomination perhaps Quentin Tarantino I
hope he does if he doesn't that'll just
be that'll just be stupid
anyway the announcements are about to
start so let's get to it for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role the nominees are Christoph Waltz
and Django Unchained he's won before
Philip Seymour Hoffman in the master
very good he has won before Robert De
Niro yes over linings playbook he's won
before why is she saying that that's
annoying Alan Arkin and Argo very good
Leo DiCaprio
before tell me Leo DiCaprio and Tommy
Lee Jones in Lincoln he's won before
okay great good job Leo I mean Tommy
fresh air by a quarry I want their
DiCaprio what is that all those are
great domination nominees are before my
time from chasing ice music and lyric by
Jay Ralph
PI's lullaby from Life of Pi music by
Michael Danna lyric by Bombay a giant
Skyfall suddenly flame is Rob
music by claude-michel schönberg lyric
by Herbert Kratz myrrh and Elaine
Lille everybody needs a best friend from
Ted music by Walter Murphy lyric by Seth
MacFarlane and Skyfall from Skyfall
music and lyric by Adele Adams and Paul
Epworth the 2012 nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are Sally Field in
Lincoln and Hathaway in lame is Rob
Jacki Weaver in silver linings playbook
is ro Helen Hunt area second of all and
Amy Adams in the mass now this wasn't
really a good graduate here for
Supporting Actress the best animated
feature film the nominees are
Frankenweenie Tim Burton the Pirates
band of misfits Peter Lorre Wow
wreck-it Ralph very good paranormal
paranormal yeah felt and Chris Butler
and brave Mark Andrews and by man hmm it
was though it was good but not afraid
for Best Original Screenplay the
nominees are bro Django and John
gaytan's for flight Django Unchained
Mark Boal for zero-dark thirty better
django Quentin Tarantino for Django
Unchained very good Michael Chanukah for
a more oh so it's Michael hammock and
Wes Anderson and Roman Coppola for
moonrise kingdom really interesting for
best achievement in directing the
nominees are David O'Russell for silver
linings playbook very good angly for
Life of Pi no surprise there he did good
job Logan Spielberg for Lincoln ice
Michael Hanukkah for a more Wow and Ben
Zeitlin for beasts of the southern wild
these are five people who are the very
best at sitting in the chair watching
other people make a believe the nominees
for Best Performance by an actor in a
leading role are Daniel day-lewis in
Lincoln Denzel Washington in flight Hugh
Jackman in lame is Rob nice Bradley
Cooper in silver yes hey buck and
Joaquin Phoenix in the master yeah there
you go for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role
nominees are Naomi Watts in the
impossible
she was good but I mean Jessica Chastain
is no dark thirty Jennifer Lawrence in
Sorocaba
Emmanuelle Reba in Namur and qua fins
and a Wallace in the beasts of the
southern wild precious aw and finally we
are pleased to announce that the film
selected is the Best Picture nominees
for 2012 are beasts of the southern wild
Dan Jambi Josh Penn and Michael gottwald
producers silver linings playbook Donna
gelati rich Cohen Eric Jonathan Gordon
producers zero dark thirty Mark Boal
Kathryn Bigelow and Megan Ellison
producers Lincoln Steven Spielberg and
Kathleen Kennedy producers Lima Zara
tim bevin eric Felner deborah Heyward
and Cameron Mackintosh producers Life of
Pi gillnetter Angley and David will mark
produces a more nominees to be yes I
need to see you more Django Unchained
I see cher Reginald Hudlin but no
director nominations and Argo
grant Heslov okay why are you nominating
the directors for these Murray
okay so you know a lot of good choices
in there some things I was happy to see
I was happy see Bradley Cooper I was
happy to see Robert De Niro Tarantino
for a screenplay silver linings playbook
getting a lot of nominations that was
great Jennifer Lawrence's Best Actress
that was really nice it's good to see
Spielberg nominated good to see
Christoph Waltz nominated as well and
I've since looked at the full
nominations list Skyfall was nominated
for Best Cinematography which is good
but of course it was snubbed for
everything else except for Best Song
Dark Knight Rises complete snubbed Ben
Affleck for director snub Quentin
Tarantino for director Kathryn Bigelow
for director what now I actually did see
beasts of the southern wild I didn't
review it because I saw it waylaid there
was no point reviewing it it was just it
wasn't relevant anymore and I thought it
was original film and different and good
in that way but I just don't think it's
worthy of a Best Director nomination it
was just way too shaky and it just
seemed like it just it just wasn't
worthy of a director nomination I don't
think and I think it took it away from
films that were directed better and I'm
very disappointed as of late with the
Academy and who they pick as the best
directors of the year I mean they've
snubbed so many directors these past few
years
also snubbed for editing I think looper
is one of the best edited films of the
year in recent memory they did the same
thing with Scott Pilgrim vs. the world I
thought that was one of the best edited
films I've ever seen and just because
it's like a fan ish movie I mean come on
also looper had a fantastic script and I
really am just disappointed in the fact
that the Academy stays so safe I mean
look at Matthew McConaughey and killer
Joe or even in Magic Mike I mean this
guy gave great performances this year
you know and just because a film has a
lot of lurid content it doesn't mean
that it can't be nominated for something
and it's nice to see Django Unchained
nominated for some things but I don't
understand how you can nominate a film
for best picture but not nominate the
director they've been doing that a lot
lately but nominating movies as Best
Picture but they don't nominate the guy
who made it it's just odd you nominated
for Best Picture you nominated for Best
Writing but not the guy who directed the
whole thing and uh where is Leonardo
DiCaprio seriously guys I mean he broke
a glass with his hand and there was
blood like just trailing all down his
arm throughout a scene and he kept
playing the scene you can actually see
it in the movie a blood all over his
hands that he wipes all over Kerry
Washington's face that's actually his
blood how is that not a dedicated enough
performance for you I just it really I
don't know I this you got me in the
moment here and I'm a little bit I'm a
little peeved at it and you know it's
just it's gonna happen all the time
people oh there and I complain about the
Oscars I understand but look I just
don't understand some of these pics
they're odd and I said something about
now he wants his performance when she
got nominated she did a great job in the
movie she did but I just feel like when
you're comatose for 50% of the movie
that that's not really worthy of a gold
statue okay you did a great job in the
movie but you spent most of it lying on
a bed you know I mean just you know yeah
so there's some good there's some bad
there's some things I'm happy to see
there's something is I just don't
understand I think I'm not I'm not like
mad it's just I'm confused that's
probably my overall word it's like I
just don't understand some of these pics
they're they're strange there are
obvious better things out there it's not
been like a opinionated I'm sorry there
are better things house fare it's like a
fact some of the nominations there are
better people in that category if it
should have been nominated that's just
that's how I feel about it nevertheless
I'd like to know how you feel about it I
am now calm and I don't care anymore
what do you guys think of the Oscars
what do you think of the nominations let
me know just rant below if you want to
rant about my video that's fine too I
don't mind that as well and as always if
you like this video you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes